after years and years of watching
YouTube for years people love people
that don't see much love just have you
to give your entire life I mean I don't
even watch television anymore
I literally YouTube don't watch TV at
all how do you start your very own one
and that's a very hard question what
most of us do how to successfully get
started on YouTube look at tutorials
we've read about it make sure you have
good lighting make sure you have a
camera make sure you have good editing
techniques and most of us don't even get
around to making that first video
because we're too nervous or too awkward
so hi my use yasmin also know there's
JAGMAN but my friends i am a person
living this shared house which is pretty
creepy because they could be listening
right now and that's embarrassing
i've just recently and moved to london
which is quite scary
I used to live in Plymouth and that's
like so even that tiny but I've heard of
this
it really is yes so I'm a person and
like you why should you be me to make a
blog or a gaming channel or yeah unless
you only have one hobby which is fair
enough to have one of it I have a lot of
hobbies I do things abandoned buildings
it's boring just [ __ ] so [ __ ] it I was
gonna be as a whatever when I feel like
it where I feel like it it's very
awkward
I'm sure gay of that it's hard so you
have a very before me before
and the sunlight is just coming down not
for very much longer
because I have a big-ass pony from my
window it's quite intimidating I don't
even have nightstand so I've just got
this this is my style
yeah always professional stop it just be
yourself and that will make everything
okay
it's what I've heard yeah how do you end
it
sick all right oh yeah first choice I'll
just see what happens
by
I watching this import I didn't know
then I have no friends I couldn't tell
thank God then it's big not for me